hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care nerd and
not a sponge yes you heard that right we
are not sponges and your skin is not a
sponge the myth that 60 of what you apply
on your skin will be absorbed into your
bloodstream is one of my pet peeves it's so
inaccurate but people who are saying this
seem so confident and it's such a specific
number that you kind of want to believe them
it's used by a lot of clean beauty brands to
freak people out about their skincare products
so today i'm going to be breaking down how
human skin works and why this is a myth
first off yeah skin is not a sponge you don't
get massively heavier after you take a bath
you don't absorb your clothes you still have
makeup to remove at the end of the day you can't
just slap food you don't like on your skin to get
around eating it you can't just sit on big tablets
to avoid swallowing them you can't just stick
your hand in vaccine goop to get around needles
none of us got massively drunk off hand sanitizer
okay maybe you did i don't know you and your life
this is because your skin has evolved to be
a really good barrier it's one of its main
functions it blocks things in both directions
it blocks substances that you put on your skin
from getting deeper into your body and it stops
important substances from leaking out from your
body into the environment if we absorbed or
lost things that easily we would have died a
really long time ago like a lot of people do
mud runs if these people were absorbing 60%
of what got on their skin then mud runs would have
stopped a long time ago after 90% of people who
did them got horrific diarrhoea for the next six
months so by default the amount of stuff that gets
absorbed when you put it on your skin is going to
be closer to zero percent than a hundred percent
but what about medicated creams and patches if
skin's such a good barrier why do these work
yeah science woman how do you explain that one
well the fact that only a tiny proportion of
all the medications in the world are actually
delivered through skin in creams and patches if it
was easy to deliver medications transdermally that
means through skin then we'd have a lot more drugs
that did this because there are lots of advantages
to transdermal medications one of the biggest
headaches in designing medications is something
called first pass metabolism this is when your
digestive system gets rid of drugs that you take
orally like in a tablet or a syrup before they
can get to your blood to get around first pass
metabolism a lot of the time you have to give
people a lot more of that medication so that
after your digestive system does its stuff then
there's still enough to get into the bloodstream
to have any sort of effect you can also just avoid
the digestive system entirely with things like iv
drips and injections and suppositories
what's a suppository it's when you you know
what what in the or transdermal delivery through
skin in patches and creams patches are also good
because they can release drugs consistently
over a longer period of time and they are a
lot less hassle for people than giant tablets or
injections so we would have a lot more transdermal
medications if we could but we don't because we
can't getting stuff to go through this really
effective barrier that's evolved over millions of
years is a massive pain in the what what in the
there are lots of formulating tricks that are used
to get things to get through the skin and into the
blood so with nicotine patches for example they
mix it with penetration enhancers that get the
nicotine to get through skin more easily the patch
itself stops water from evaporating that keeps the
skin moist which makes it more permeable the
sticker also stops things from rubbing off
and even with all this extra help with current
transdermal drugs there's still about 10 to 95
percent of the drug left on the skin unabsorbed
at the end so why do some things absorb through
the skin into the bloodstream well it mostly
depends on what the substance is which is why
that blanket 60 number looks so dodgy to people
who studied pharmacology firstly there's the size
of the molecule the smaller it is the more easily
it squeezes between all the stuff that your skin
is made of sort of like how you try to streamline
yourself when you get through a crowd your skin
is also made up of watery and oily parts things
that dissolve in water tend not to dissolve in oil
and so a substance has to be the right balance
of water and oil soluble to get into the skin and
then also leave the skin and get into the blood
so as you expect the drugs that are in transdermal
medications tend to tick off all these boxes and
things that aren't don't and it's the same for
other things that touch your skin your skin also
doesn't have the same permeability all over and so
the amount that gets absorbed also depends on what
part you're talking about this table over here
shows how well three different substances absorb
in different parts of your body if you look across
the table then you can see there's a massive
variation in how well different substances absorb
if you look down the table you can see the massive
range depending on what part you're putting on
some parts of your body are better at absorbing
things so your armpits your ear canal your jaw
your scrotum other parts of the body like the
foot your palms your forearms are less permeable
one thing to note about this table is this
is percutaneous absorption so that just means
absorbing through the skin not necessarily getting
to your blood there is a lot of stuff between the
surface of your skin and your blood you can see
this on my handy model the surface of your skin is
up here you apply the stuff here and then it has
to diffuse through all these layers before it hits
the blood so only a fraction of the stuff you put
on the surface of the skin will actually make it
down to the blood and that fraction depends on a
lot of things like the blood flow in that area how
thick these layers are you might also remember the
fda studies that got reported as sunscreen soak
all the way into your bloodstream the abstract
of the first study had a bunch of percentages
and some people thought that those percentages
were the amounts absorbed they weren't they were
actually the coefficients of variation which is
a measure of how repeatable the measurements were
but you can actually roughly calculate what
percentage does get absorbed into the blood
from the data in the paper a redditor did these
calculations and it turns out that for avobenzone
0.011% gets absorbed into the blood plasma then
doesn't that mean skincare doesn't work science
woman skincare doesn't have to get that deep and
not at that higher concentration most skincare
ingredients actually work in the epidermis which
is in these top few layers so when you put the
skincare on your skin it doesn't have to absorb
all the way into the bloodstream a lot of skincare
ingredients actually work really effectively in
the stratum corneum which is this very top layer
if you want something to get into your blood and
work somewhere else then it has to get through all
of these layers and then once it hits the blood it
gets diluted because we have about five liters of
blood that's about 13 of these i mentioned this
before but there are formulating tricks that can
get things to get into the skin they're used in
transdermal patches and creams they're also used
in some skin care products i mentioned covering
stuff up with a patch that stops the ingredients
from getting rubbed away plus it also keeps
moisture in and moisture helps disturb the skin
a bit and help things absorb better there's also
penetration enhancers which are ingredients that
help skin absorb things better some of these
work by making the stratum corneum which is
this outer part of the skin more liquidy and the
stratum corneum is one of the strongest barrier
parts of the skin and so that can make a big
difference some of them disrupt the proteins
and the oils some of them hydrate the skin sort
of like what a patch does there are lots of these
in skincare this includes alcohols glycols some
essential oils urea fatty acids and even just
water you can also use special delivery systems
like liposomes in the products there are also
lots of tools that can help with penetration like
ultrasound electroporation iontophoresis heating
and microneedles some of these disturb the barrier
and some of these push the ingredients into your
skin in other ways but in standard beauty products
a lot of these aren't designed to maximize
absorption a lot of products are meant to stay
on top of your skin so sunscreens for example if
you absorb them then they're not going to be very
useful because they'll be below the bits that you
want to protect so maybe with a few freak things
applied to specific areas of your skin in specific
ways can absorb at 60% into your bloodstream but
for the vast vast majority of things that you put
on your skin 60% is a massive overestimate i hope
you like this video if you have other myths you
want me to debunk leave them in the comments
hopefully we'll see this myth around less but
i'm not that optimistic to be honest it's one of
those myths that never seems to die but hopefully
this video is useful maybe you can use it in your
internet arguments you can just copy paste it into
the comments instead of wasting hours of your
life if you like this video give it a thumbs up
you can also subscribe for more videos like this
you can follow me on instagram and check out my
blog if you like beauty science and i'll see you
next time to hopefully not talk about sponges